acheter une propriété pendant une
pandémie c'est possible mais vous avez
deux contraintes majeures 1 le 23 mars
dernier le premier ministre et le
directeur de la santé publique du québec
ont recommandé de ne plus visités de
propriété privée et pour que ce soit
plus clair encore l'organisme
d'autoréglementation du courtage
immobilier au québec a interdit aux
courtiers de faire visiter des
propriétés à leurs clients et cette
interdiction s'applique aussi à ceux qui
voudraient vendre ou acheter une
propriété sans courtier
vous devez donc vous rabattre sur des
visites virtuelles et si par les temps
qui courent vous trouvez que certaines
vidéos sont un peu moins belle que
certaines photos sont un peu plus flou
eh bien il ya une explication à ça c'est
que les photographes professionnels ne
peuvent plus se rendre dans les
propriétés privées
alors ce sont les propriétaires eux
mêmes qu'ils réalisent leurs visites
virtuelles leur foi avec les moyens du
bord
si malgré ça vous êtes intéressé par une
maison sachez aussi qu'il ya un deuxième
inconvénient très important vous ne
pouvez pas faire faire d'inspection
parce que les inspecteurs en bâtiments
sont sous le coup de la même
interdiction que les autres cependant
sachez qu'à partir du 20 avril les
inspecteurs en bâtiments pourront
recommencer à faire leur travail mais
seulement dans des constructions
résidentielles neuves
si malgré ces deux contraintes vous
voulez toujours aller de l'avant et bien
les notaires sont là pour vous recevoir
parce qu'ils sont considérés comme non
un service essentiel dans la mesure où
vous respectez les règles d'éloignement
physique
quoique depuis le 1er avril dernier il
est possible maintenant de compléter
toutes les transactions notarié en ligne
incluant la signature finale qui peut
être fait par voie électronique
alors bonne chance
[Musique]